uh i want to pull the store if i have to
do it this this story infuriated me to
to know when
yeah it's from me i'm sorry i
interrupted you but so this was great
it's important this is nearby yeah
mediaite says beltway climate protest
backfires as video of parolee pleading
he needs to get to work goes viral these
people are climate change activists who
blocked a highway in maryland
a man gets out of his car and says
hey i gotta get to work i'm on parole if
i don't get to work i'll be put back in
prison they don't say a word they ignore
them they don't care he says please give
me one lane let me go to work they
ignore him he starts yelling at him
ripping their signs the police come in
and arrest him yep here's the here's
here i saw the video of them pulling
these guys off i thought it was great
i'm like pull each and every one of them
off and move the traffic he got arrested
he got arrested and then this guy
guido uh reichstager who was there
launched a fundraiser trying to raise a
hundred thousand dollars
saying help this man out he doesn't know
who the guy is he doesn't know the guy's
name he is trying to raise a hundred
grand off the back of a man whose life
he destroyed
these people this is the trolley problem
they would pull the lever to kill you in
a moment if they thought they were doing
good now here's the reality of it
the trolley problem presents you you
guys familiar with it right yeah we all
love the trolley problem there's five
people in the tracks the train's going
to come and hit them if you pull the
lever you kill someone who is not in
danger but it's one person versus the
five
you see that is a very simple way of
explaining these problems you can see
five people in danger you can see one
person not in danger would you pull the
lever the reality is these psychopathic
narcissists who would destroy your life
for their righteousness cannot see
anything you're right so here's the
better trolley problem a train is coming
the track is completely clear someone
runs up to you and says hey if that
train keeps going eventually someone
will die
now if you pull that lever and divert it
you'll kill that person
what do you say
that's what they're doing
they know they're destroying lives they
know they ruin this guy's life they're
trying to make money off of it a hundred
grand he doesn't know this guy is he's
not going to give him any money
and they don't know that climate change
is actually going to cause the problems
they think it's going to cause
no one is known as smart enough to
predict exactly how it will play out
well and their solutions to climate
change are going to cause even more
drastic
and horrible problems
for
the world i believe so they don't really
care about people at all and they don't
care in the same way that these biden i
guess voters who just hated trump
don't care about outcomes for for people
exactly and then
the fact that this man launched a
gofundme seeking a hundred grand is the
perfect example of who these people are
they don't care they hate trump and they
will try to make money off you mm-hmm
that's so brutal so
i didn't know that that had gone on that
the man was on parole he was going to a
job he had to show up at or he was going
to get thrown back behind bars if he
didn't show up to work on time
he get thrown he get thrown in jail and
he didn't drag i saw the video of him
like grabbing a sign but do they just
knock it out of their cars and just pull
the people off the street because it's a
type of assault i saw a woman there too
and i was actually going bravo get these
people off the road
and allow people to get moving yeah they
may they may not have to work or they
may want to sit home and they may want
to cause trouble
but people have lives to live they have
children to feed they have mouths to
feed at home you know what this is first
i i respect non-violent civil
disobedience they want to come and they
want to block the highway bravo do your
thing you got your attention
attention congratulations the police
should then come in and arrest them
within a matter of minutes clear the
road you've made your point you got
arrested
you caused a traffic jam but everybody
carries on and their mind is a minor
inconvenience the police were not doing
anything well cops were letting there's
not a lot also they've defunded the
police the same people wanted to fund
the police i didn't mind that somebody
pulled them off the road they didn't do
it in a violent way it's like dude this
is a road for traveling on
take your protest we get we get the idea
move it along right i didn't think
pulling these guys off the road was an
act of violence when you've got
thousands of cars backed up and the cops
just let them sit there
so i'll tell you something let's ramp up
the fear so you see how they treat this
one man they destroy his life they try
to make money off it greta tunberg
famously said we want to end fossil
fuels now paraphrasing we don't want to
wait till 2030 we don't want to wait
till 2023 we want to end it now
do you know what happened if we shut off
fossil fuels like that right now
i think the estimate is 60 million
people die overnight
die overnight
yup i would think that at the econ
everything would collapse
without uh fossil fuels we don't have
electricity we're going to plastics
plastics are built from oil man that's
right but the immediate the immediate
reaction is
without oil if if we just stopped all
use of oil right now
first diabetics they're they're done
because insulin is kept refrigerated if
they can't get power if they don't have
some kind of alternate way of of you
know backup power
they die many people are reliant on heat
from fossil fuels in cold climates older
people they die
when you get these activists like greta
tunberg who outright ignore countries
like china or india and just rag on
europe and the united states say they
want to end it today
you might think
oh she's just ignorant if only she knew
that what she was proposing would kill
millions of people she would not
advocate for it no no she would and they
do know and they do it anyway well they
made her a celebrity and i mean they
they put at the top of the ticket for
their environmental you know ideas at
the time i think she was what 16 or 14
yeah that was their spokesperson well
you know what i i strongly encourage all
of these young people to be like greta
tunberg drop out of school
hey i've met some smart people who
aren't in school i'm on the campaign
trail a lot of the smartest people i
meet the greatest kids i meet are the
ones that are homeschooled that's why
and you can spot them from a mile away
i'm not sure that greta would be on my
list of smartest people but
i don't know her so i don't want to i
don't want to like what would greta even
say to those points you were making i
don't think she would know what to make
of them because she's so dumb hyper
fixated on this issue like it's a like
she does have autism and i it is her
special interest
but it's
being made into her career path she was
like these people have a fantasy of
unlimited economic growth
and
i think she called it a fantasy and it's
like yes
because what we've discovered is that
while you can't keep building buildings
or producing widgets you can make
digital property and crypto and things
like that so we can have endless
economic growth when you have a virtual
we have a virtual world where you have
virtual goods that are just data in a
machine
so you can actually uh there there are
people who used to have jobs making
warcraft gold
just playing a video game
and then
giving the gold to someone else for
money you can produce things and have
economic growth that doesn't impact the
physical reality granted playing the
video game does have an impact with
electric uh electricity consumption and
things like that she clearly just
doesn't know what she's talking about
you can have unlimited economic growth
it's actually the nature of our species
and reality is unlimited economic stuff
but it's the rate of economic expansion
that can become dangerous you don't want
it to grow too fast too or maybe you do
because uh you know as the story goes
back in the turn of the century 1900s
there were these reports in all these
big newspapers that we're gonna have a
manure crisis in new york city that
there was gonna be horse manure piling
up in the streets it would be so much
you would be able to get around anymore
and nobody would live there and then the
car got invented yeah same thing with
carbon in the air right now it would
imagine if they went back and killed all
the horses because they were like no no
more horse manure we need to stop horses
now it would have been tragic the same
thing with trying to stop carbon
producing machines well you you laugh
but aoc put out a green new deal
fantastic farting cows remember that yep
yep farting farting powders we've got
they had more common sense back then
though they didn't have this lunacy back
then i think if we can get i like alex
alexandria or ocasio-cortez because i
feel like she's at least real a real
person whether or not she's misguided or
not she's at least like a real normal
person but like if you talk to her about
carbon recapture tech and you lay out
the graphene production in the industry
that we could create i think you could
bridge a gap between climate activists
and national industrialists we could
make the united states the greatest
industry on earth just making the
cheapest graphing to make you know 21st
century industry right and clean up the
air and live in synergy without
preserving the planet or cleaning up the
air
i think greta's cause
is really just to lower the standard
quality of life in the west and
reserve
you know things like meat and air
conditioning and flying on planes for an
elite class look what she did when she
was like i'm going to go to the the u.n
and take a boat instead of flying and
then she went on this really expensive
fiberglass ship with a crew that kept
her safe and it was like hunt i forgot
how much it cost to do this journey but
it was a huge stunt that consumed way
more carbon than actually just flying
all about resource hoarding yep it's a
scarcity mindset
i do believe she she's been used by her
surroundings like her parents i think
kind of pushed her in that direction and
then because they're entertainers
but but i gotta i gotta push back aoc is
not a real person
relative to most people in congress
that's what i mean i think she's here
she's she goes on instagram
and people think they have a friendship
with her because she's in her kitchen
and she's having wine and making dinner
and they go oh she's my friend and
that's where she's been able to connect
with people and
and young people
and this is where we're li and i do
believe we're seeing a a huge movement
of young people getting into politics
because they realize the last few years
of politics affects their lives
it affects their lives it affects their
uh ability to interact with the masks on
their face and all of the shutdowns and
the force vaccines and all that i know i
can't say that i'm sorry
but um
you know she got was able to get young
people involved in politics i think she
is leading them astray but what we're
seeing now is a huge movement of young
people and i think they're becoming
conservative because they're looking at
who tortured them the last three years
which party was torturing them who was
behind some of this and we're seeing it
in our campaign we're seeing a lot of
young people coming in and getting
involved i think they're going to vote
in droves well mary you're a young
person what do you think
well the left is obviously outdone the
right by miles in
having their finger on the pulse of
culture
and the right is only just now catching
up
um
and
it really hits on what you said about
like the masks because that's i think
when it touched a lot of people's
personal lives for the first time that's
like
it is literally right in your face
muzzling yeah hand over your mouth
and they were told by by social media
and the and the entertainment world this
is good you're doing a good thing but in
their brain they're thinking okay all of
the people in my social world the
celebrities who i like are telling me
this is good and we need to do this but
deep down in their heart they went this
sucks yeah young people are hungry for
more but do do you think the the
gen z is going to
so i want to make sure i clarify
republicans have more kids than than
democrats liberals conservatives have
more kids than liberals do
and so there's more gen z conservatives
by a tiny bit according to pew but in
general among like normie gen z do you
think they're like
leaning more
anti-establishment anti-woke not
necessarily right-wing
or do you think they're left can you ask
it are they leaning more biden because
biden's that's right yeah because i
think they're seeing him as very uncool
i don't know am i right or wrong it
depends like who who does gen z want to
make the butt of their jokes that's like
really what you have to watch because
humor is all they have i don't think
they're leaning
any direction
they're kind of just hopeless and
uh
hopeless yeah yeah i mean their sense of
humor is like
this post-post post-ironic
yeah
it's so nihilistic
uh i think they're
like alienated from well they should
vote for politics
they should it's very it's very late
1920s it feels like weimar germany where
they needed a villain they needed a butt
for their joke and hitler pointed them
at the jews and then they had their
villain like we need to be careful and
it's not just that
they hate themselves too like i feel so
sad when i see uh people a little bit
younger than me out in public because
they just
look so uncomfortable in themselves and
i think the pandemic really exacerbated
that
because they were socially isolated
they
got a terrible education
over a screen
for years
thankfully i was spared from that but um
it's going to be really weird
because there's this this covid period
it's going to have a profound impact on
people even though it's only a couple
years
so you've got millennials and older
who lived a life outside of the
lockdowns until the lockdowns happened
so they were adults but then you've got
gen z and jen alpha
who
developmental years were happening
in this lockdown period which is going
to like scramble their brain
well that's really this is where oh my
gosh as a mom i'm just
very sad about what happened what we did
to our kids and just listening to you
talk about
their sense of humor we tortured our
children
and it's not the moms who did it we but
a lot of moms and dad felt like they
were being forced to abuse their
children every day having to put a mask
on their four-year-old and send them off
or the parents who were on planes and
they were like put the mask on your
one-year-old and they were like they
keep taking it off and they're like
don't care get off then yeah it's just
like and it's forcing these parents who
love more than anything this child to do
something they know is wrong and it is
sick as hell and we will never ever
forget that thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there